tanto el presidente francés como el
primer ministro británico acordaron y
coincidieron en la importancia de un
futuro a largo plazo para afganistán y
también de hacerlo desde el consejo de
seguridad de las naciones unidas un
vocero de downing street- que es la
residencia oficial del gobierno
británico dijo que el primer ministro en
esta llamada resaltó la necesidad de la
comunidad internacional de unirse y
adoptar un enfoque unificado sobre
afganistán tanto en reconocer a
cualquier gobierno futuro y de trabajar
para prevenir una crisis humanitaria y
de refugiados de hecho el primer
ministro británico contempla la
posibilidad de convocar a una cumbre
extraordinaria de los países del g7 que
recordemos son las democracias más
grandes y los países más ricos del mundo
para tratar esta delicada situación
humanitaria en afganistán también
mccrone y johnson hablaron en la
necesidad urgente de evacuar al personal
de los dos países
a afganistán y de hecho hoy el ministro
de exteriores británico dominic rap
confirmó que enviarán 200 integrantes
más del ejército británico para atacar
evacuar a 350 personas ciudadanos
británicos y también ciudadanos afganos
que han trabajado para el gobierno
británico también el parlamento de este
país que está en receso de verano ha
sido convocado de manera extraordinaria
para este miércoles 18 de agosto para
tratar esta delicada situación en
afganistán